let the battle begin with the arrival of
director Todd Phillips long-awaited
Joker movie a new challenger has entered
the arena in hopes of becoming the new
best Joker actor ever his name were keen
Phoenix his game well doing his job and
delivering the chilling kind of
performance he knows it's required of
him but possibly also to throning the
late Heath Ledger in the process since
the announcement of Joker fans have pip
Phoenix and Ledger against one another
placing bets on whether or not the
newcomer could shock and scare the
audiences as a failed comedian turned
crazed killer Arthur flag as much as
Leger did through his turn in
Christopher Nolan's The Dark Knight
the debate over feelings and Ledger as
the Joker began months ago but with the
world finally able to see Phoenix strut
his stuff in clown makeup and the
tattered suit the fight is no longer
theoretical so now that Joker has landed
in theaters who played the character
better
Joaquin Phoenix or Heath Ledger plenty
of people are totally floored by the
work Phoenix did in Joker so much so
that they now consider him better in the
role than the late Ledger some even
think Phoenix is the best Joker actor
point blank
are you having me negative thoughts all
I have
one Twitter user wrote with all due
respect to previous Joker's and to the
great Heath Ledger Joaquin Phoenix is
the best Joker he has everything it
needs
we finally have a proper actor playing
the character in a very unfamiliar new
shape
if Ledger's are straight flush Phoenix
says a full deck another fan tweeted I
thought it would take a long time before
someone delivers Joker better than Heath
Ledger as it turned out it only took 11
years and a certain Joaquin Phoenix this
fan continued to gush over Phoenix his
performance in another tweet writing
Joaquin Phoenix should get an Oscar a
Golden Globe an Olympic gold medal a
Nobel Prize a Ballon d'Or knighthood a
Champions League win a medal and a
Presidential Medal of Freedom for his
performance as a Joker bollywood news
and gossip site coin wacom aimed to
settle the debate once and for all
they're breathless verdict Phoenix wins
hands down Phoenix's portrayal of Arthur
Fleck is going to be remembered for a
lifetime his portrayal is so powerful
that after the film was over I was so
sucked into his world and I felt like I
needed a good sleep Phoenix's
performance makes you feel sorry for
being part of this society and hence I
say McKean Phoenix's Joker makes Heath
Ledger's Joker even more badass than he
was but alas there can be no Phoenix
Joker lovers of Alf Phoenix Joker
detractors in the outlets comprehensive
ranking of every Joker polygon place
ledger circle spots higher than Phoenix
with ledger coming in second place
behind Mark Hamill who voice the ace of
knaves on Batman the Animated Series and
Phoenix coming in fifth just ahead of
Suicide Squad actor Jared Leto polygons
Susannah polos said of Phoenix's turn as
the iconic comic villain his Arthur
Fleck is impossible to look away from
even when you desperately want to
Phoenix ways the grimaces shuffles and
delivers terribly involuntary Parekh
Sims of laughter even as he openly weeps
he just does it in service of a
character who isn't particularly joka
like other than in the most superficial
ways comparatively polygons Patrick
Williams wrote that Ledger delivered a
performance quotes so good it's worth
forgiving it for all the terrible
Halloween costumes and cosplays that
inspired wanna see a magic trick
I'm gonna make a pencil visible
disappear on a different note jesse has
interrupt the week wrote that Felix's
version of the Joker falls short of not
only the magnitude of ledges iteration
but also that the power of every Joker
actor who preceded him patentee wrote
even an actor gifted as Joaquin Phoenix
struggles with this Todd Phillips -
Joker is a vastly more focused
disciplined undertaking than something
like Suicide Squad with a committed and
often mesmerizing performance from
Phoenix yet it still often feels more
like a composite of influences than a
real original this is all very well
performed by Phoenix it's also more
indebted to Joker's past and the movie
seems to understand the movie wants
desperately to make the Joker feel real
and resonates and Phoenix is best but
ultimately this may mark another
transition for the Joker a turning point
from prestige role to party trick with
so many different versions of the Joker
in existence no singular take on the
iconic villain can be universally
heralded as the best there really is no
best Joker actor it's entirely
subjective that said of being able to
find even a little bit of greatness in
each of them just shows how iconic the
Clown Prince of Crime really is check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]